Today is a traditional Chinese holiday.
We celebrate the Dragon Boat Festival by holding...
...yup, you guessed it, dragon boat races.
Oh and of course, we eat Zongzi, kind of like a Chinese version of a Tamale.
The history of Dragon Boat Festival dates back to as early as 484 BCE...
...which is almost like 2,500 years ago.
During that time, the famous Chinese general Wu Zixu was unjustly accused...
...of essentially giving bad advice to the king,...
...who was then forced to commit suicide by the king, not emperor.
His body was thrown into the river near Suzhou...
...which is kind of like the Venice of China.
But a decade later, people realized that Wu was actually right about his advice.
And was wrongly sentenced to death.
The result was that Wu became a celebrated hero...
...and the King, Fuchai actually committed suicide when he realized that he was wrong.
Oh yeah, and his kingdom was taken over.
Anyways, nowadays people generally associate this festival with another famous figure,...
...Qu Yuan, who is a famous poet.
He committed suicide in the Miluo river.
After Qu Yuan's death, local residents wanted to collect the poet's body...
...so they paddled out on boats while beating on drums...
...to scare the fish and evil spirits away, naturally.
They also threw rice snacks wrapped in bamboo leaves into the water...
...to distract the fish from eating his body.
Since then, on the fifth of May of each year on the Chinese Lunar calendar,...
...Chinese people do dragon boat racing and eat Zongzi...
...to commemorate these two historic figures.